estate abituando troppo bene avere
sempre più visse in 3d e oggi giorni
iachini non so fare i video ragazzi sei
anni di youtube 4 milioni di iscritti
non so parlare né fare una intro sto
dicendo bull e ritornare sulle alpi miss
3d ma mi dispiace oggi facciamo e
turisti di perché sono troppo tempo
senza fare è più il quad rischiamo
l'astinenza grossa è qua ci denunciano
mica ragazzi roba seria
nella gt ragazzi è pervenuto che sono
video sono fa rigeneratrice la sua happy
with clic clac ora andiamo col primo di
today prestia gamer to end the rest
turno ma che cazzo è di tutti credo che
ok ma io e tutto quello che ho capito
quindi devo stare attento alle cose che
succedono che bello
neanche a scuola ero così attento
ragazzi volevi che cliccati sul canale
testa di coloro invece non lo faccio
click sinistro ok a devo che ci mette un
po ridere questi giochi moderni 2017
cioè dopo uncharted c'è questo non ci
arrivo subito però pian piano e le cose
si fanno perfetto ma deve durare ancora
tanto starò oddio a perfetto ma basta un
altro tempo lo finisco gioco quanto dura
oddio santo stai andando verso la moneta
grazie a gesù bene sicuramente sono il
53 secondi meglio spesi di tutta la mia
vita ragazzi anche di albertino secondo
me anche lui è rimasto così contento
oltre orange facciamo questa perché sono
troppe cose difficili facciamo una cosa
in cui sono un fenomeno
halloween è visto abbiamo sfilato sempre
bello tornare sui miei ragazzi se poi mi
danno un sacco di gioia dopo un sacco di
gioco di merda un gioco di merda
difficile capirlo punto di halloween
lo so che ai centrali buchi c'è sempre
avuto problemi di questa vena
però le portava allora cambiamo su tutti
che devo 66 è questo intendevo per serio
resto central altro buco no
e adesso c'è il prezzo troppo gusto zio
nothing calmati ha detto non data vorrei
farvi passare un brutto quarto d'ora
questo devi capire che dopo ti tortura
anche la famiglia sen
bene anche rifarlo uguale adesso che era
giusto quale problema al cervello ai
esattamente oggi zio
no no eh vabbè parchi a [ __ ] che botta
c'era un'altra via gesù ti ringrazio vai
[Musica]
altro che vittoria questo è meglio
perché i ragazzi gli iscritti si
conquistano non vincenti livelli ma
facendo i fichi tipo cosiddetto dei
simili
olè olè che lo sta facendo quello non
interessano i tuoi piedi non sono
feticista andate tutti a cagare perfetto
dai leghisti sono tecnici 6 10 6 zione
che ci sei veloce esplodere in quanti
pezzi white signor importante covinto
zombie apocalypse saggiati va
sicuramente se in hd sarà eccola la
parte il gioco del secolo papà voglio
comprare una cauna car una macchina che
avevo di tanto traduco o male papà
voglio comprare una macchina non me ne
frega un ca nun me ne frega va bene
perché vuole comprare una macchina
poverino gli la coppia anche io ho avuto
la mia prima macchina a tre anni poi non
ho mai avuto la patente pratica nuova
moda ragazzi usiamo un nonno come fosse
una rampa
[Musica]
allora zio scusami non volevo farti male
però ok lo so che quello è tuo habitat
però devi darti una calmata
allora frate dedica non non deve
esistere in questo livello caffè non
deve sparire cosa non capisci del fatto
che devi sparire fammi capire ma cosa
fosse successo dio perché vi sia
attaccato la faccia per generi ucciso
come già fatto cioè un lo spirito lì non
c'è chi nota svolazzo nel nulla mi ha
ucciso ok allora perdonatemi nonni ma
non riesco ancora ok perfetto passato
perché ci sono così tanti ostacoli in un
solo livello barca era impossibile lo
odio questo gioco mi dà fastidio mi urta
ok rifare roba molto più 3 di f3 di f
non dovrebbe essere difficile prendere
una donna ma che figata mafiose e
bellissimo poi tiro di in trip o chi era
questo e un [ __ ] livello agli altri
che richiedono abilità che io non ho
parte livelli così ma inizia bene sono
contento adesso sai tempo gusti 4chan
nota ha posto poco parco al awsat
architetti colpo a baby gaga non è così
difficile
l'ho detto è fermi tutti ok
perché se fatta la terra ok per far
niente
nuovo tipo di pignatta ragazzi perché in
realtà luke voi non lo sapete ma è un
tipo di ascia loro impianti nelle
persone fantastiche
no è stato carino e prima che non è ok
record non lo so chi ha fatto suo
livello più velocemente di me
impossibile ossa rotte 2 solo per il 9
merita zero solo per il nome scelto
pixel per di fuori gol va bene
pensavi che volessi dire ma che è invece
non l'ho detto che sono una persona
originale cosa è successo non ho capito
c'è tanta eco tra vittoria tra l'altro
come cosa giorgio dei missili scrive ai
missili
ok non pensavo fossero questi missili
pensavo fosse una roma un po più
contenuta come si marca [ __ ] perfetto
quando ti colpisce la freddo
ragazzi questa è un allenamento per
quanto trump e deciderà di fare le cose
sul serio ha quindi dovrei essere anche
grazie donald ok gesù di nazaret
vai vai vai premiarlo prendi l'altro
prati altro perché o ci fai
porca eva lercia se avessi fatto il
salto giusto effetto l'effetto ok best
su mai difficile
vorrei difficile non è difficile tua
madre treppiede ma per che cosa sta
facendo
e vabbè metterà impossibile
ok perfetto ne manca uno che manca un
bacio bacio stata come tua madre mai
[Musica]
perfetto ora è così che si conquista la
patata è così che si conquista il
prossimo 93cento erba non impossibile
per cannati ecco per far fatica che non
secondo non sono morto fermi tutti e
vabbè la rappresentazione della free
zone anche qua con la madonna mi chiama
livello olimpiadi sta minkia però grazie
vi ritornato indietro il borgo perfetto
fermi tutti che devo ce la posso fare
per rifarmi
ok e questo l'abbiamo ripresa di
mettitelo nel culo per ok al piano un
salto ho fatto bene
[Musica]
cosa è proprio un bel gioco come mi
piace mi piace un sacco di roma ogni
volta che arriva domenica che bello che
vada a giocare ha detto sua madre non
c'è verso di firme e poi guardo mi
sismica anche la pagina non ci crede
neanche il mio internet
ok ok vai vai allacciati le scarpe non
ce l'hai più le scarpe male ecco la sua
scherzando ragazzi impossibile è
impossibile un'ora io ci sto provando mi
sto rompendo veramente le noci che c'è
come è possibile
avremo esigo di vederne play voglio
rivederlo c'è ma vi pare che con tutti i
tentativi che ho fatto alla fine ho
vinto così con sé non ho capito
vabbè lasciamo perdere che non tra i
primi ormai diventata la roba lì si
capisce più niente sue ragazze andiamo
sul rocker simulato e proviamo l'ultimo
livello di oggi che mi sembra bello per
chiudere
sembra un po una supposta fa più male di
non ha supposto molto più bella somma ma
non c'è una vittoria non so simulare il
razzo ed è carino sembra un rossetto te
lo danno in omaggio da kiko questo
quando compri cosmetici importante che
non va contro le cose li proteggono le
cose ma non fa niente
va bè ragazzi io basta questo episodio è
successo di tutto va bene questi
problemi che ci è piaciuto ragazzi cose
deve riuscire momento è un bel like
anche ai social come tiziana il sensore
fiscale ci vediamo al prossimo video
ragazzi occhio che grazie
che peso vabbè avete capito da ragazzi
[Musica]